dieses verbrechen spaltet vor 35 jahren
ganz deutschland ist eine mutter
wirklich dazu in der lage ihre beiden
kleinen töchter kaltblütig zu ermorden
der fall monika bremer bewegt bis heute
damals 86
das kann man nicht vergessen das
vergisst man nicht dann kommen leicht so
vorstellung zum zuge
irgendjemand muss es gewesen sein also
er war es auch mit mit sicherheit mit
ich bin fest von der unschuld mandanten
erzeugt mache vor
die ermittler sind sich schnell sicher
der mörder von carola und melanie kommt
aus der eigenen familie
es können nur der vater oder die mutter
gewesen sein
was ist passiert und wie lebt es sich
mit der schuld die eigenen kinder
getötet zu haben